beaucoup d'amis et de proches ont
assisté vendredi aux funérailles de
jeannette de poils belli mais aucun
représentant des gouvernements le jeune
sans histoires a été poignardé à mort le
18 octobre d'un stationnement de son
école par des inconnus kabouli trop gars
avec tes le masque est en fait ça
à quelqu'un qui est vraiment gentille et
comme j'en fais avec tout le monde
s'est fait dire à juste parler de cette
rencontre a été vraiment ta oui
j'adorerais son petit frère qui
apprenaient à jouer du piano et rêvait
de devenir rappeur contrairement à la
médisance qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux le jeune jana il n'avait aucun
lien avec des gains ou des bandes de
voyous sa tante dénonce le traitement
médiatique de ce meurtre d'une violence
inouïe en plein jour elle se lève comme
un autre alors des chaînes vraiment une
simple au lieu de venir découvrir qui
était cet enfant dit elle vous l'avez
dépeint comme le membre d'un gagne salue
une influence très douloureuse sur la
famille de djanet de sentir que sa vie
compte moins que celle d'un autre jeune
que leur deuil compte moins que celle de
long john cette force association
expliquerait qu'il y avait eu moins
d'empathie moins d'indignation public
envers ce meurtre sordide comparé aux
réactions qui ont suivi celui du jeune
thomas trudel tiré à bout portant près
de chez lui un double standard à si
fréquent dans les médias selon cette
militante anti raciste on est habitués
dans les médias à associer les visages
des personnes noires à des histoires de
criminalité donc les gens associent tout
de suite les deux skiffs quelqu'un un
jeune homme noir de 16 ans meurt 11 et
est ce que c'est un criminel est-ce que
c'est lui qui est elle qui a été violent
ce genre de question ne se pose alors
que quand un jeune homme blanc du même
âge meurt c'est pas tout de suite
l'hypothèse qui nous vient en tête en
estrie pizza c'est la même chose qui
arrive est la même chose c'était c'était
des violences la famille de janet y
avait invité la mairesse valérie plante
a assisté à la vigile organisée en sa
mémoire elle a plutôt envoyé deux
représentants en la voyant la semaine
dernière rendre hommage à thomas trudel
en compagnie du chef de police ils ont
eu mal
je comprends leur douleur dit elle
chaque mort en août une de trop mais
pour moi il n'y a pas de double standard
dans la protection nos jeunes le god
willin' reach out
and only
landry which tôt le premier ministre a
publié dimanche un message sur la
violence par armes à feu en nommant deux
jeunes assassiné récemment son silence
sur la mort de jeanne haag de poils
belli a soulevé un tollé qui l'a forcé à
rectifier le tir j'ai pas voulu être
ce soit là les paroles je peux pas
imaginer
la situation dans laquelle ils se
retrouvent de perdre un adolescent sa
famille espère que le souvenir qu'on
gardera de jana y est celui d'un garçon
gentil qui aimait star wars l'homme
araignée la musique et qui aurait voulu
être un artiste ici sophie langlois
radio canada montréal